okay let's do it again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to another episode of your
favorite podcast
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's up y'all another episode of
riffing with griffin
good to be here once again and i want to
thank you guys for sharing subscribing
uh you know staying true sending
messages
because i really do appreciate it and so
you know we here again
back at you with
all right that's good
yes you know i'm reaching over because
as you guys know i'm a one-man show
one day i'm gonna get a producer one day
i'm gonna get a producer and we're gonna
do it right
uh but anyways you know thanks for
watching we're from with griffin once
again uh
listening subscribing i don't know how
you get it spotify apple i don't know
where it all is right now i don't know
how it all works but
i'm glad you guys are here every single
week i do appreciate that so thank you
for that
um big week this week i just i want to
start it off by just saying
get out of vote man today's monday that
just came out so it's monday for when
you're listening to this and it's you
know voting day
maybe you've already sent your things in
maybe you're going to the
the voting thing for tuesday right cause
i think it's the third
right let's see what's the date right
now yeah because today must be the first
um yeah yeah so november 3rd
so let's see what happens you know what
i mean but listen no matter who you
um are voting for or what your beliefs
are
you know make your voice heard i mean a
lot of people say oh well my vote
doesn't count it doesn't matter
i mean it actually does matter because
you know you you
for yourself you've put yourself in the
mix
you know you've said hey i i want my
vote to be counted i put it out there
and
that energy of trying to be a part of
the system i think that's good i think
it's a good thing to carry it down to
you know family friends loved ones
neighbors if we you know it's like a
collective feeling of like we are
a part of something bigger than
ourselves which is you know
uh being in this great country so go out
and vote you know i get a lot of people
that hit me up you know
it's like if you say it's it's crazy to
me because like if you say
anything bad about trump for for
instance
the trump supporters they get super
angry you know they're angry people
even though they're in you're in the
white house then they write you back
with just
rude ignorant comments like they think
that that's what's going to
get it back even though you know they're
not you you won
you're guy's there your guy's in the
white house he's been in the white house
he's doing whatever he's doing
has been doing so to be so angry about
it i don't get
and then the other side is just super
sensitive so
either way that's what i'm saying so i'm
not here speaking about my own personal
what i want to do i'm just telling you
what i would like you to do is no matter
who you're going for no matter what your
beliefs are
get out there and vote just be a part of
the system so
because you know remember in the last
election 2016 you know it was like oh
there's no chance this guy
has to win so if you're anti-trump make
sure you get out and win
get out and not win you know get out and
vote uh because you know
you can't listen to polls don't believe
cnn don't believe msnbc
because they were all night they were
telling us there's no way this guy can
win this is impossible
and now it's just they were just
flabbergasted because
because they're basically useless you
know to me they're like critics polling
people like who's
who who's who who's these people on
these polls
how do they know how is it accurate is
it an online thing
or like you know are there are a million
people going oh this
or they're deciding by how many people
do they actually poll you ever ask that
like it's just
it's i had this talk about critics a
couple weeks ago it's the same kind of
thing where
i don't understand polls unless there's
some kind of like
online poll and you can see oh 3 million
people
did this poll and then you could be like
oh well that's a pretty good uh
indicator but sometimes it's like oh
it's out of twenty thousand people
this is some it's supposed to be some
indication that
what everybody thinks so i don't know so
it seems pretty spooky to me
where these numbers and stuff come from
and with all this stuff that goes on in
the world so
i don't know how polling works so don't
trust the polling you know they say
biden's up by eight eight points
whatever that means
but who knows what's gonna happen night
of when people are voting and then you
have the electoral college then you have
like
this is going to be a mess you know so
either side if we have a strong turnout
in voting at least we'll have
a better indication of what people want
you know if we get
eighty percent of uh registered voters
to vote that'll be more than it's been
in
many many many years because listen
we're gonna have to deal with the
all right uh are all the vote to be
encountered
uh is the mailing safe you know all
these things that they're just it's just
being set up for just a big
mess that this election won't be decided
for it could be
who knows how long it's going to take
for the actual election to be like
all right we finally have a winner so
who knows but
just uh my big thing on that is just to
say hey do your part
get out and vote you know even if you
think it doesn't matter
i say it matters to you it matters for
you being
your own collective well-being just
being like oh i'm a part of this
you know i'm here in this country i pay
taxes so go out and do that part you
just get out and vote so i encourage
everybody to vote so please
do that okay uh what else is going on so
last week i had this big
you know i just was talking about the
coronavirus and then and the charts and
the numbers and just trying to figure
out like
what this all means and i got some
messages
i said put send me messages i said send
me comments write comments
whatever some of the comments are rude
you know it's just some people don't
listen to everything that i say
because they just want to pick one part
and then send me a really stupid message
like you know you're so ignorant and
then they then they say
exactly what i said later in the video
but that's the only part they wanted to
watch
so it's like if you're one of these
people if you're not trying to have like
a healthy back and forth why even send
me a message
i don't care about you you know if
you're gonna come at me with some
negativity
kick rocks man don't listen to my
podcast i don't give a
[ __ ] okay i just don't you can leave
if i lose you because you want to just
be a rude ignorant [ __ ] then go ahead
then you know you could just there's
plenty of podcasts
you know what i mean it's not a lot of
people to listen to this one anyway so
why are you here
being one of the negative people all
right so forget that
i give too much attention to trolls as
it is you know people always tell me
that why are you talking about the
trolls
you know what you know why honestly
though just real quick
let me talk about the trolls for a
second because they have nothing
else i'm doing them a service like the
good people you guys are here you don't
need pats on the back all the time
and i always say thank you for
subscribing and sharing and thank you
for being here thank you for listening
but the haters man they have nothing
their life
is meaningless so they they go on
to somebody's podcast just who am i i'm
just a regular dude this is just i'm
using this media format you can too
it doesn't matter like you know you
could make a podcast and have people
listen to it
so they go on and then they just want to
like you know troll they want to say
rude mean comments and they think that
like yeah
and so i am acknowledging them for them
because that's what they need
i'm actually doing i'm doing a service
for them
i'm giving their life meaning so when
you're trolling me and you're saying
rude things about my girl you're saying
you're calling me names
and i acknowledge you i know you need
that
you need it because you have nothing
else
so hey congratulations you know
but anyways back to it so last week i
was talking about the coronavirus and i
was just showing the charts
of course this by up uproar in the
comments uproar and
i got emails messages i just want to
clarify again
really what i'm talking about i don't
claim to understand how all this works
i don't think that there is anybody that
i know just a layman
who just just a regular person who would
say oh i
understand how coronavirus works i
understand how these charts work
i understand how you can read the
numbers i understand why
uh some places have been open and some
places aren't you know
you you could you could claim you you
don't know man most of us don't know
and so when i look at the charts all i
was basically saying is regardless
of population i'm just saying the
the coronavirus looks like it's doing
the same thing
in a 40 million state like california
and uh 25 million stayed in florida or
texas like the big places
the charts seemed to look the same it
started here it went
up and went down and now it's going it's
going up and it's higher than it was
before so i'm saying
all i'm saying is if the virus is doing
the same thing in multiple locations
and you go all right so what do these
things have in common you look at one
and you go well this state's been open
the whole time
the other state's been closed most of
the time or you know
whatever you go well the virus seems to
be doing the exact same thing so if
that's the case
why are why are the places that are
closed closed if it's going to do the
exact same thing
that's basically what i was trying to
get at you know um
and then right now recently you hear a
lot of like uh you know the cases are
rising
uh there's more and more people seem to
be getting it uh we're not being safe
enough or you know the protocols aren't
being followed you know and i am an
advocate of that
i i hate wearing a mask but i think you
should wear a mask look i hate wearing
seat belts sometimes it's uncomfortable
but
you do it because it's for the safety of
you yourself and others
so listen i say again i'm not trying to
put out some message like i'm
anti-information
no it's just i'm trying to find out why
are we doing what we're doing
why is california closed you know why is
california closed and
say some other place isn't and the virus
doesn't seem to be doing anything more
or less
than than other places you know
um but then you would say well look at
the numbers more closely so some of the
people that hit me up and it's so
interesting to me is like
scientists i had a couple of scientists
hit me up and
wow i really appreciate uh you know
intellectual types
you know you listen to my podcast uh for
whatever reason you know i'm not a
scientist uh you know
i went to college i didn't finish i went
into entertainment i started working and
you know i my dream actually is to go
back to college and get a psychology
degree
and you know anyways but that's besides
the point so i do appreciate you brains
hitting me up and you're trying to like
educate me and you know
one guy was like i was really
disappointed in your take
you know i okay i get it but you know
i'm trying to clarify
what i'm talking about i'm just talking
about as a person i don't understand how
this thing's
thing works like why are we doing what
we're doing
you know so and it's it and it's and in
the scientists people
they're ready to tell me they're ready
to be like let me come on your show and
i'll
explain it to you and it's what they
don't understand is how funny is it that
it takes a scientist to explain
like that's what they don't seem to like
they need to register that oh yeah like
i actually am a scientist i study this
i've actually
been a part of this and here i am you
know
you know angry about you know what
someone who doesn't know
is just talking about just trying to use
common sense common sense doesn't always
work in situations where there's facts
and information that
you know you don't understand how it
works or how it connects that's the same
thing with
this coronavirus like we can make
assumptions and but
i'll give you an example it's like you
know in the nfl right now um
cam newton for the you know the the
patriots the quarterback starting
quarterback for the
new england patriots right he actually
got coronavirus
and since then he's played like [ __ ] all
right he just has been awful
he couldn't practice but you know he was
sick i'm not saying
it's because he got coronavirus while
he's playing like [ __ ] but i'm saying
is that a factor if you were studying if
you were trying to track and see
how the virus affects people would you
use that as an indicator to be like well
here's someone here's a world-class
athlete
uh you know about to be 30 years old he
got coronavirus
and is he still playing at world class
athlete uh status
there's probably some other people that
have gotten it that went on to do but
there's an example of somebody who's not
playing the same i'm not saying this
because of coronavirus let me say again
but is that is that some
information that you would put into play
to try to be like
how is this thing affecting people
because it seems to affect people in
many different ways
some people have no symptoms some people
have flu symptoms some people they lose
their
um smell and taste other people they
have headaches other people have cough
you know
like there's all these different
symptoms and then they're still trying
to figure out how it affects people
afterwards
so what i'm saying is is this evidence
that it has an
effect even on someone like that i don't
know here's another one
ezekiel elliott the run starting running
back for the dallas cowboys
i think people forget that he had
coronavirus before the season started
and he's playing like [ __ ] right now
he's not playing the same
but i mean what are those factors i mean
he is older now uh running back the the
shelf life for running backs is very low
i mean it just could be the wear and
tear on his body and now he's just
breaking down
uh you know or could the coronavirus be
a part of that
i'm not i'm not saying that's what it is
but you know it's some evidence that you
look at but it's one of those things
where you go
i don't know how this works i don't know
or or understand all i know is this is
this is a confusing time now let's talk
about this what i really am frustrated
about that's going on
right now in society what's going on
like
do we care about health and safety
really like
like you're sitting here and you're
listening and you could be one of these
people who's really adamant about
we need to do better with coronavirus
people need to wear mass
people's social distancing and and you
want to count all the deaths
look how many people have died you know
you want to count that and you want to
make that the most important thing
but damn do we really care about this
because
collectively it doesn't seem like we do
because you look at like baseball okay
so here's a
here's an example money's on the line so
anytime there's money on the line it
seems to me that like
how we treat the coronavirus is
completely different
so the baseball okay let's go actually
actually let's start with basketball
basketball basketball was like hey let's
have a bubble
because it's the kind of thing they have
a schedule they got to play
seven games in a series they want to get
all the games done and they just don't
want to have to stop
games they don't want to have to forfeit
games they don't want to have to move
the schedule
let's go let's make sure everybody's
clear so we can finish the season
they did it they finished it there we go
no fans in the stands
the bat the those the basketball
which is predominantly black sport
had the microscope on them and they went
into a bubble and they finished their
season
i think hockey finished their season too
i'm just not a hockey fan so i don't
want to speak on it so i don't even know
if they
if they crowned a stanley cup champion
but here's one thing i do know nobody
was talking about it nobody cares
you know it's weird that if that
happened and i didn't know about it
cause i'm usually a sports person you go
oh
that's pretty cool yeah the stanley
cup's going on so they it wasn't
publicized i don't know if they canceled
games or anything like that
but the nba ended up not having to
cancel games they finished their seasons
they had a few people that
had some hiccups along the way and then
then it went on you know
all right so then you have uh baseball
started you know
now baseball was they said we don't care
i mean
look they may not have said that but
that's what they said they said
we are taking a risk versus reward
assessment
of playing the major league baseball
season without a bubble
we're taking the risk we feel like if
people get sick
we'll just postpone games if people get
sick they'll take them out
most of the time it's a lot of social
distancing in baseball
and they just said we're gonna go they
went on the season
and there was a certain point in the
season where they had canceled 40 games
no one was talking about it nobody cared
it just it just was one of those things
where
you know you you you know you the season
went on
some people got sick and that was the
end of it where's my phone
because there was that you know and so
they finished it and they crowned a
world series champion
but even in the world series um that
that that one player got sick
let me see let me get his name i'm
looking it up dodgers
corona corona
virus that's how you got to look up
justin turner
so apparently justin turner this guy
during the game i guess he had taken a
test beforehand they got the results
who knows when they actually got the
results you know it's the world series
you know if you had to ask the guy hey
do you still want to play yeah play
yes his teammates hey should he play he
might have you know i think
maybe they would have said yes but by
the way just a side note people need to
be protected from themself
that's why you have laws and rules
that's why you you know the the
governors go hey we're closing the state
down because we're trying to protect you
from you because if it was up to us we
would just be willy nilly which
seems that people are willing nearly
anyway so anyway baseball goes on so
this guy justin turner
he's celebrating with his players he has
his mask on he takes it off he kisses
his wife but his wife
if he has corona his wife has corona you
know so they
you know they deal with that so there's
this big you know uproar
up to do about it but i don't think
anything's going to come of it it just
is what it is the guy
tested positive the whole you know like
why are people getting mad
during the world series that somebody in
baseball had the coronavirus
when they decided all season that they
don't care about a bubble and they don't
care if they get it or not
so the world series comes a guy gets it
and everybody's like oh my god what are
we gonna
how can they do this i just feel to
myself it's a little disingenuous at
this point like
all they cared about was money in the
first place they got their tv money they
got their revenue
they even had people in the stands you
know they even had like all social
distancing in dodgers stadium the
outdoor stadium
or wherever they were doing it in
florida wherever it was you know they
had you know
there's people in the stands even in the
football games you see like half
capacity or even like a third capacity
there's people out there you just kind
of go all right
you take a risk reward assessment and
you decide is this okay
so here's where we are but my problem is
people use numbers to their own
advantage
when it suits them in their argument and
if we're just going to use numbers
i got a problem with that because one
they're trying to open up theme parks
again the major league sports with fans
in the stands
are going you they got college football
going kids aren't even going to
real school but they can play college
football it's like all that makes me
feel like they don't care about health
they care about money first all right
and again
you take a risk reward assessment and
decide
is this worth it and should that and you
have to ask yourself
what do you care about do you care about
the numbers do you care about these
deaths
or do you only care about the death
because it's because it's political
you know because you feel like you're
making some kind of point because
we're we're so divided as a nation all
right so listen i'm not a fan of donald
trump
i'm not gonna i'm not i'm not a huge fan
i have my own reasons
you know i don't know i'm not gonna go
into him here so i'm not a fan of his
kid either like the way he was talking
right so his kid i think donald jr or
whichever one
comes out and he says you know he got
real lamb basted for this because he
said
something like uh there's you know the
death toll is
practically nothing what he didn't say
practically nothing but
whatever he said he did there
there there he did imply that yes
people have died but it's not as many
deaths
as you would think it's meaning that
there's an acceptable number um
[Music]
acceptable number of of of deaths
you know that that he thinks well this
is okay
if this amount of people die this is
this is you know
this makes it okay you know so here he
is right here um
[Music]
he said almost nothing those are the
words he used
you know so then somebody came up and
said you know well over a thousand
people died today
for whatever day that was a thousand
people died that day
because of the coronavirus
you know and so they were on it like you
don't care about these thousand people
so i'm asking you what's the number
that you honestly don't care
like here we are the world is in uproar
in upheaval the united states i mean
financially this is
ruining people okay it is
depression is up suicide is up
um divorce rates are up like all the
things that are
direct because of having to be
quarantined and having the stress of
not knowing if you're going to be able
to pay your bills and all that stuff so
there's this
effect not to say that you know that
means that hey we just opened up
willy-nilly
no i'm not saying that but you have to
acknowledge that there is an effect but
i'm asking you like what's the number
that you care about the most
because that thousand people that died
seem to be
like politicized as being like oh well
you don't care about
this guy doesn't care and i ain't
defending this mother this dude
i ain't defending him at all all right
but i am bringing up to you you
listeners you're people that are
listening
the people that hate him and hate trump
the people that you know
are you know the commoner virus we got
it all the stuff you're talking about
the coronavirus and what we need to do
as a nation and
all you mask people wear your mask all
the time and
do you you seem to put a lot of energy
into the coronavirus
which is which is fine i'm not against
that
but ask yourself what's the number that
you kind of still go well life should go
on
now you may say well there is no number
i think you're lying
you know so this guy just said look hey
a thousand people died today
out of 350 million people in the united
states
uh okay
is that an is that uh enough to say well
we should still keep
everything shut down and
not reopen the country is that the
number
um i don't know you know i guess if i'm
being honest i go
all right i guess we all could take a
risk-reward assessment and be like
i think that we should open the economy
back up
and deal with the consequences of
whoever gets sick and doesn't get sick
it's just it's just a new normal people
are gonna get covered i mean that's a
that's a feeling that
i'm sure a lot of you have and it's an
unpopular
feeling for some people but those people
that think it's unpopular
you're always you're using these numbers
so over 200
000 people have died from coronavirus
united states out of the 350 million
however many americans we have i think
it's almost close to 400 million
americans right
okay so
i looked something up and i want to talk
about it
so the chronovirus these deaths in the
carnivores
they would go under the category of
preventable deaths
preventable meaning your choices
and actions your choices and actions
that you made
you could have prevented getting corona
and eventually dying from it okay
preventable death
so i looked it up and i was like what
are the other
preventable deaths in the united states
and what are these
numbers and my question to you is as
you're listening
do you care because
if you're someone who is like especially
you scientists that like to hit me up
you want to hit me up and you want to
talk about how serious this is and the
coronavirus is so serious okay
i'm not saying that it's not guys i'm
not but i look this
up you know and a lot of this
information is from the world health
organization
all right annual number of death causes
and this is
preventable deaths preventa
preventable deaths the number one on the
list guys
210 between 210
and 448 000
americans just in the united states
die from medical errors
in hospitals every single year
let me say it again 200
000 to 400 000 people
die every single year
because of medical errors human error
does that number move you does it make
you want to go
whoa we need to
reevaluate the hospital system does it
make you go
well are doctors going to school enough
is there should there be more oversight
does that number move you or is it a
number that makes you go
well human error is a part of things and
these are
although they were preventable we have
to
accept that and we have to just you know
i'm still going to the doctor i'm still
going to the hospitals
it's just a thing you have to deal with
is that a number
is that how that makes you feel how does
that make you feel when i say that to
you that
almost 448 at most almost
500 000 people die from hospital errors
every year number two on the list
okay number two on the list hard numbers
smoking tobacco 435
000 people die
every year from smoking
related illnesses do you hear what i'm
saying
so tobacco and that's a preventable
death because if you don't smoke you're
not gonna get these things
so so right now we're up to almost a
million people
are dying from preventable deaths
we're going to add to corona so if you
add the corona into that
already that's going to be a million
but does that move you are you moved to
tell people to stop smoking
are are we going to move to shut down
tobacco companies
are we going to like what are we going
to do what what are we going to do about
that is that a number you care about
435 000 people
die preventable deaths
and it tickles me because it doesn't
take me i'm saying
doesn't say that right when i say it
tickles me it just bothers me that
i see people on twitter and instagram
who smoke
and they want to talk about wearing
masks
and they want to talk about what we
should be doing for coronavirus
ad nauseum they want to put up tweets
and posts and like
you if you would just do this if you
would just do this
we wouldn't have this you know problem
with coronavirus
while they lighten their cigarette shout
out
okay shed it
hypocrisy here's another one number
three on the list
being overweight and obesity
causes a hundred thousand
deaths and some of these other lists i
looked at that number is even
larger no pun intended
and you know obviously there is a
difference between
obesity related diseases
and other things that come you know
from being overweight i mean it's more
complex than just being like
hey people are dying from being fat i
mean it's more complex than that
okay but the point is it is in a
category of
preventable deaths just like corona
preventable so if we
eat right take care of ourselves you
know a large
i bet you a large number of that would
go down
and i'm a part of that i'm trying to do
that now because of that
but what i'm saying is does that mean
number move you
just a hundred do you not care about
these hundred thousand
people or do you only care about
coronavirus
you know alcohol 85 000 people die
you know infectious diseases traffic
collisions they have
all these different types of things that
are preventable
but the two to get me the most is
smoking and
you know smoking well three of them over
being overweight smoking and
medical errors in hospitals i'm just
saying all this energy that a lot of you
are putting out
all this energy about you know you want
to like talk about the coronavirus like
oh are you putting out that same energy
about people not smoking
the the leading cause of death in the
united states
that is the leading cause of death in
the united states all right
i don't hear you talking about that
let's let's
you know so i'm just saying tone down
the rhetoric
those people have made a choice and
that's what we're saying to ourselves
do we care about the 400 000 people who
are dying from smoking
i would like to say i think i care but
then there's a part of me that goes well
that's the choice that they made
they made that choice right now
obviously
people are doing that to themselves
they're not spreading
you know except for secondhand smoke and
all that too i would love to look up
those numbers and see how much
secondhand smoke is killing people you
know
but you know but those people are dying
it's causing stress in people's families
too you know
you know people we have to worry about
heart disease and we have to worry about
lung cancer and all these things that
are
that are a strain on your family and
their emotions and feelings because you
made a choice that you don't
you said i need to smoke so you know you
have that
but i'm just saying if we're gonna use
the numbers
all right then let's talk about all the
numbers
let's talk about having a better world
all the way around
but i don't want to just hear about
these 200
000 people that have died of corona like
yours like you're
that that's the most important thing in
the world to you right now
you know because we are living in a
world right now where
we're seeing things look baseball
completed their season
uh you know uh there are states like
south dakota
who they say the numbers are rising in
south dakota
you know because but they're they're
their governor doesn't have they're not
mandating that you wear a mask
you know i'm saying there is a risk
reward factor that we have to decide
where we really are in this and look at
a
bigger picture of what's going on in our
world in our country
and really look at it and be like what
do i really care about
because don't don't throw out the 200
000
americans that have died of coronavirus
and that is like making you go
well we need to do more when you're
living in a country where
over a million people every single year
die from preventable causes
just i just want to put that out there
something to think about
this does not mean i'm saying we should
just open up willy nilly
i'm four masks i think that this
obviously there's other
mid there's other factors that go into
how an infectious disease spreads and
how it's different from these other
things
but obviously if you're saying if we
would have worn masks if we would have
social distance early
we could have taken the curve down and
we could have beat this thing
therefore because we didn't do that it
is preventable
these were preventable deaths so we're
going to add that to the list of already
a million people already a million
people preventable deaths
but you know you want to just everybody
wants to run their mouth as if
the coronavirus is the only thing that
we should care about in the world
and it's not so again i ain't defending
donald jr at all but when he says
hey it's prac
you know practically nothing to death
rate you know whatever the words he used
when he says that and you hear today a
thousand people died
just knowing when you start if you want
to look at numbers look at all the death
numbers every day and you're going to be
like oh [ __ ]
let's start caring about our world all
the way around
not just this especially not just this
because it's political
it's politicized i want this same energy
after the election i want this same
energy about us being a safer
community a safer united states i want
that to be
the thing you talk about more than just
this virus
because this is gonna be going on for a
while now guys i don't care what
whenever the vaccine comes out
you know there has to be trials for that
and i hope they don't just rush that out
for because of public pressure you know
i hope you know we
you know you have to ask yourself too
are you going to take the vaccine if it
comes out
at what point do you go or i think that
they've done enough so i think that this
is safe
like at what point are we going to be
like i think we can take our masks off
and get out get out into the world and
be and be
normal when is that when when is that
going to be and will it ever be is this
how it's just going to be that we're
just going to be walking around
keeping our distance from people you
know
what what's the world going to look like
and whatever it's going to look like
it's going to take some time before
we really get back to like the
nitty-gritty of
normal whatever that is everyday life so
anyways
i know i'm still going to get messages
from people and i do appreciate it
listen
i'm just having a dialogue with you um
but you just can't hit me back right
away
and i have no problem with you hitting
me up and being like yo this is how i
feel about that just come at me with
some respect man don't come at me with
your nonsense the two scientists to hit
me up i truly appreciate you guys
sending me
very very long very nice emails
explaining their side and their point
and i appreciate it and i hope that i've
clarified
what i'm talking about right now but i
just want you scientists to talk about
you know
because scientists like to say hey we
told you about this
we knew this one guy hit me up he was
like one scientist was like hey
we knew in february we were shutting
down because we knew that this was
this was a serious thing you know
because they're in the know they got the
knowledge they're scientists okay
i do think that sometimes scientists
take the the
the doomsday approach too though they
have a doomsday outlook on things and i
don't know if it's always as bad as they
think it's gonna be
and it's always not as good as the
pessimist thinks it's you know as the
the realist thinks it's going to be or
whatever the you know what i'm trying to
say
you know so i appreciate you hitting me
up continue to hit me up
you know we can uh just have a dialogue
and then i can like i
i i eventually would like to have a
couple of these
geeks on the show to like ask him some
questions because
i don't know man i remember watching joe
rogan's podcast and
i don't know if this guy i don't
remember but he had a coronavirus guy
on a guy was just talking about it and
he was convinced that it was going to be
a hundred million people were gonna die
and like he just had like a weird you
know
i don't know i don't think he said die
but it was like it was like a gloom and
doom outlook that made me everybody
watching that go
oh man i hope this guy isn't right you
know but you know not all scientists
have been right in the past they made
predictions and it didn't work out
but you know hey they have to think for
the worst you know that's that's part of
what they do
they think a worst case scenario and
let's prepare for that
so anyways that's my little uh
that's my little spiel about
that so again continue to
listen you know and like i say i
would be more than happy to take emails
and questions and that kind of stuff you
have like a statement you want to write
just be respectful
then i'll talk about it you know what i
mean i'll be like hey this guy said this
because like i i am not saying i'm right
i'm not saying i'm right or wrong i'm
just
this is how i feel about it and you
could be like you know what i agree with
some of that or i don't agree with this
and this is why
that's how you should hit somebody up
because that's how you have a dialogue
with people man
you can't just be like you idiot and
then
spew off the things that you you know
what i mean it's like
why would i interact with you so
yeah all right coming up next uh
rachel's back
and we're just gonna yep yep for a
little while and um
i hope you enjoy peace hey guys thanks
for listening to riffing with griffin
and i just want to talk to you today
about
lucy nicotine it's a company founded by
cal tech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative
finally tobacco alternatives that don't
suck
look the product was researched and
developed for three years to be made for
people
not patients lucy has created a nicotine
gum with four milligrams of nicotine
that can comes in three different
flavors
winter green cinnamon and pomegranate
pomegranate
favorite flavor i wish if i was a smoker
this would be
the flavor i would go for lucy also has
a lozenge with four milligrams of
nicotine and a cherry ice flavor
each and every flavor actually tastes
great
and it's a convenient and discreet
products can be enjoyed anywhere on
flights at work
on the go even at the gym
hey look i don't smoke and i don't like
being around people that smoke
you know it stinks their breath stinks
their clothes stink
you ever been to somebody's house and
you know they're a smoker it just has
that smell
are you ever been in like a smoking room
at a hotel
you just go ugh what is that it just
makes the back of your throat hurt it's
just
all together it's terrible and it just
it's not good for your health you know
and that's why these couch tech
scientists came up with this in the
first place
listen guys it's 20 20. get rid of your
cigarettes
unplug your vape throw out your dip and
get loose
gum or lozenges this is the real
deal a subscription to lucy comes
directly to your door
each month it's so simple and you don't
have to leave your house because lucy
has
delivery down riffing with griffin
listeners
go to lucy.co
and use promo code griffin to get twenty
percent off
all products including gums or lozenges
that's lucy dot c o and use promo code
griffin at checkout
also look i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical
but remember lucy.co and be sure to use
promo code griffin let's get back to the
show
you looking at yourself well i can't
really see myself that far away
[Laughter]
but crossing my fingers
oh it's okay it's fine just are you
still nervous doing the podcast
yep why because you like rush me
and not release last minute i just got
off work
showered and now i'm like
like waiting on me so i'm not waiting on
you
oh man you asked me
i tell you the truth you're right this
is a truth-telling podcast you could
tell me the truth i like it
it's fine are we going to play flitzy
we're both barefoot you don't have to
say that
oh so it's okay for you to reveal stuff
but what i reveal what i want to reveal
so we had so we had a good halloween the
other day like we can't i can't show the
pictures
of rachel's complete she had two
costumes for me it was really nice
yeah a costume for me and a costume for
you yeah you wanted she wanted to i
don't know why you wanted like the maid
i don't know i just thought like you
keep saying you want me to clean up
so yes i would like you to i got a
little maze outfit
and i was going to clean up but we
didn't get to that part
[Laughter]
from your favorite movie we watched the
whole series harry potter
yeah um and i fell in love with that
movie too
i didn't read all the books i read the
first book back in the day
but um i just got a little
what's her name um harry potter's
girlfriend
no see it's not see this is where i wish
she would have done her research
okay i just so she was trying to be
hermione
what's and do the accent do how are you
doing i was like hello ron
but then he didn't want to be ron yeah
okay harry
i wanted to be harry but then that you
had you didn't have a scar on your
forehead well we were gonna draw that in
but you needed to be jenny
if you were gonna be harry potter so i'm
jenny you were jenny
and then i was harry you if you were
hermione i would have to be ron
even though i think ron and hermione
would have been better together but she
didn't write the books like that
but anyway the costume i actually liked
that costume better
right but yeah little tie it was cute
sexy thank you
and we won't go into i love halloween
but i
love dressing up so you know
that you love holla it's hot you always
say every holiday you say is your
favorite holiday but you say halloween
is your favorite holiday well i love
them
all for what they are
uh so you let's talk about this first
so so i get a text from your mom today
okay well we have to back up
okay go back up so today well
back up a little bit it's sunday night
yeah you're fine bridge like that
and um so every sunday afternoon we do
the zoom meeting with my family i
couldn't be there because i worked today
so um in the we have a family group chat
and for some reason eric is in it but
he doesn't get the message i don't get
the messages
that's still kind of if you want to see
my phone
i don't get the message okay so he he's
a part of it but he doesn't get the
messages so i thought it was a safe zone
to be like okay eric's gonna be you were
gonna be on the
zoom call i knew that and so i just
texted them
right before the zoom call saying maybe
help
eric come up with a proposal
and then i like misspelled all these
words so then i like i
sent another text saying like um
just help him like plan
an engagement nobody said anything
like that not one person said anything
okay
so that makes me feel like they don't
want me to marry you
you know there's a part of me that also
felt that way
like not one person said anything about
i'm bringing this up next week by the
way
because that now well i was just hoping
they would do it without me on the call
right right i don't really want to be
involved but i want to be involved yes
you say you don't want to be involved
okay so then you said my mom texted you
someone text you with a night here's an
idea for you and i was like okay that
was kind of strange
but i thought like oh well here's the
this is like the pressure coming from
all sides like
um it's time uh here's some ideas get it
get it cracking
but now that i know that you asked
everybody to do it not one person
said anything right everybody was all
whatever about it
so that's kind of weird yeah they just
yeah
don't like me they don't like you maybe
they don't like me i don't know
but we don't care i don't care we don't
care
i don't give anything riffing with
griffin fans
maybe you can help eric come up with the
proposal idea
yeah i kind of want to be surprised so
don't tell me wait a minute now you want
to be surprised
yeah you don't you s this is a surprise
as i'm gonna get
she does not want to be surprised okay
so tell me like
what is what are some of the ones you
just absolutely
can like do not do this
well it's hard because since it's corona
virus still
like it's still kind of weird to do
anything in public
right but you don't like public anyway
right is that what you always say i mean
you don't want an audience you don't
want an audience no
but at the same time i do want it like
recorded so maybe find someone to record
it no i don't you don't want an audience
but you want it on tick tock
i don't know i don't want an audience
but
i want you okay all right so no
you don't like you don't want it in a
big crowd so like at the clipper game
out yeah that would be too embarrassing
it's like being put on the spot is
definitely like
i mean i know it's like putting on a
spot type of moment
mm-hmm but like yeah but not with like a
thousand like i'm just not good at like
being put on the spot okay so you don't
want you wouldn't want it in public
so like yeah anytime like a clipper game
like any type of
you wouldn't you wouldn't want it to be
on the jumbotron
rachel will you marry eric you wouldn't
want it either like no that'd be
terrible
not for me i mean i guess i i don't that
doesn't appeal to me either though
i mean i'm afraid like i just could
imagine my face and what it would be
doing
and that's all you would be worried
about she'd be looking at that and my
hair looked like yeah
you proposed to me with my hair like
that rachel always talks about this part
on your right now i have by the way
it's not straight so i'm telling you so
you're not well you told me
wow on camera how embarrassing
like as we're recording your parts no
it's good now you fixed
something different with it um i have a
widow's peak is i think what it's called
and
i think i have a weird thing like that
right here too i think that's what that
is so
it just first i think it's also a
cowlick right
in front that like my my hair like
won't be exactly straight oh but
i mean i just need a hairdresser eric
[Laughter]
anything else princess
[Laughter]
no but you know if you're gonna be on
camera your mom actually gave a really
good idea but i'm not going to tell you
what it is since you would be surprised
okay i don't know if i'm going to do
that but i mean i told you last night
but like
um my i was talking to my cousin amanda
and she gave me some brilliant
ideas of what her friends have done
right and my favorite
you know um was a dolphin
engagement a dolphin yeah so they
went to like disney world or like sea
world or something like that where you
could like
swim with dolphins and then when they
went out
each dolphin had a letter or like a
poster maybe
saying like will you marry me peta would
be
it sounds like peter would be furious
about this well now
so that's out but that's now out i know
because if i say to you right now
if i say to you rachel we're going to
see world you're going to be like
i'm stuck but i can't take you anywhere
right now
okay well no matter where i go you're
like is this that is this
i'm just saying that was my favorite
proposal of like what i've heard so far
do you have any good ones you've ever
heard um no they're all just
it just doesn't matter all this
grandiose it doesn't matter like hot air
balloon or
you know the sky riding uh you know a
lot of them like on vacation
or something like that i mean did you go
to prom i did go to prom
because i think that's the same type of
thing
like you know when the guy asks the girl
like to prom and then they make that big
like
gesture all right oh that's you know you
know what
i never did that like that because i
went to an all-boys school
so we had to go like so we had our
sister schools and so you just kind of
had to know who you were going to go
with it wasn't like you could do it at
school where you could be like
you know see yeah see i never went to
prom so i never
well that's because you were dealing
with somebody who was like older than
you right
right he wasn't allowed to be around
high school girls
i mean he was only three years older
than me but
you make it sound like i dated old guys
well
i mean
[Laughter]
not back then um yeah so you so what did
oh so you never but you
took him didn't you still take him out i
mean um no we didn't go to prom we went
to
um winter formal but we didn't go to the
dance
we just like went out in a limo with all
my friends
first and then um and then during prom
i think we just went um
we did our own thing and went skydiving
skydiving i almost like blanked that out
of my memory
yeah that sounds romantic though it
actually was very romantic until
another guy is strapped to your back
right oh yeah that's true then you're
like oh
what about my what happens wow that that
is kind of
yeah that's weird yeah it is weird and
then so like he's like looking at you
like i love you baby
while another man's on you
well you're not even really looking at
them because
like you're going down at several times
you have to jump down
after each other like you don't go at
the same exact time
yeah that is weird yeah yeah you have a
lot of weird things like that that's
like that one guy
i do i never even noticed think about
that one guy who like
got a couple's massage for you guys and
so instead of him making a move
oh yeah that's true he brought another
guy over to the house
and then he you know so two masseuses
came over so another guy's touching you
while he's laying nick it's like
doesn't make any sense to me well
i mean it's about having fun i guess
you can't worry about the guy like i was
a weirdo it doesn't matter he's not with
you anymore
he lost out um tell me this you've been
proposed to before though right
i've been proposed to a lot without a
ring
i've also proposed at one point as well
how did you propose just
um drunkenly
[Laughter]
so romantic
little little vodka tonic and you were
like i want to
marry you i mean i was with this guy for
like five years
and you know i kind of i was at the
point where like i wanted him to propose
but he didn't so i was like i'm going to
do it
[Laughter]
did he ever propose no oh
i've never prepared he he always never
wanted to get married i should have like
you she don't know i should have known
but at that time i was like young and i
was like i'm not getting married either
at least not to that guy so he proposed
who else proposed i remember i remember
we talked about this already the
the uh the army guy he proposed how did
he propose though
over text obviously
oh another keeper
and then
[Music]
well there's a few other guys
wow see it's all coming out right now oh
back in your hell's angels days
i mean i was in my prime
everyone wanted to lock me down but
i was searching for the perfect man and
you found him i found you
you were supposed to say that i
shouldn't have said it i'll let her say
it but we all know
well i'm trying to lock you down i'm
like you're locked out what are you
talking about we're locked down okay you
gotta
you gotta this is lockdown you got a pro
uh what is it a
promised car you know okay um
yeah i'm not in a rush either you could
take your time if it
needs to have like a year's
plan no engagement i just wanted to
marry i wanted to marinate you know i
will i do
i would love some suggestions you know
what i mean if you people got because i
have already gotten them some people
said oh i did this i've done that you
should try this griff you know so
i don't know maybe some people got some
good ones out there but actually i would
like uh the female
uh out there to like send what what
they because like guys is going to be
like
guy stuff well what's guys stuff you
know guy stuff is like at the clipper
game
you know or it's like some kind of like
but there's no clipper game going on
but just that kind of like oh so or like
in that
little okay so imagine the game going on
and you know those
bubbles the squares that people could
put their face in
oh yeah yeah yeah so you're gonna do it
on there
we're not going to do it like that okay
i don't know we're not going to do it
like that
i have but see the thing is is like i
know you
so like like i said when she's when i
say she don't like surprises
she don't like surprises you know so
it's like i don't
so it's like i i need to like know ahead
of time
here are three or four things that you
really like and then
we have to make sure the ring is like
because of let's say because i know how
you're going to be
if i do something that it's like too
much of a surprise
and you don't like it you're not gonna
like that because you're already gonna
be dealing with if you like this ring or
not
if you like the ring or not so that's
gonna be well that's stage two
the fake disappointment of that until
you have it on your hand and you're like
[Laughter]
looking at it how would you even know
you've never even had a ring on your
finger before
oh i've worn rings before
never a diamond ring all right from a a
guy all right
no never a guy all right well we'll
figure it out so guys send some ideas
ladies guys out there send some ideas
for that i'd love to hear that
um okay so other thing is like we're
gonna talk about is
so bachelorette the bachelorette yeah
rachel i watched a bachelorette and it's
bananas right
yeah okay first of all let's admit that
you never wanted to watch
[Music]
i don't like those shows i don't even
like those shows i've never watched the
full series of a bachelorette
either i i would you know what it is for
me is i reject the premise
because yeah right because it just it
seems to me it seems like you're
why is everyone fighting over this one
guy and like this one girl
yeah they're kissing everybody i'm like
what is this ew how do you find love in
this
and i don't even know do you know how
many do you know if there are
a lot of bachelor or bachelorettes that
have stayed married
like this long honestly i don't know
eric
because for me i think more people will
stay we just admitted that we don't
watch it
no no what i'm saying is i would like to
know how many people how many
relationships are actually still
together from the bachelor because i
know i think that there are more big
brother relationships probably than
there are bachelor relationships
because the people that go on big
brother they they meet they have this
shared experience and then after the
show they end up dating and then
because of all that shared experience
then they end up getting married they
have something other than
love in common yeah they had this like
you know all the things that makes more
sense they experienced that that
that 90-day whatever it was that they
experienced they're not necessarily
going
in for looking for love right right well
anyways so you got this girl she's 39
apparently she's been on the
bachelorette a new bachelor numerous
times she was like
one of the finals and then like
apparently she like rejected the guy or
it didn't work out
and now she's there now i talked about
this on my own because you were like we
we couldn't do it the other time but at
first i thought
i don't like it because just if i'm
being 100
she i thought she was too old right and
not that she's too old so much as like
she's too old and these guys are too
young but now i'm starting to realize
she's just too insecure yeah
you know sometimes it it takes years of
lifetime experience to even be secure
enough in yourself
you know sometimes it takes people a
while to be secure with
their body with their emotions
with you know even just being okay
with like even dating someone who
your friends or family might not like
but you like
yeah and like
that also comes with like a lot of times
with like different races and different
religions with people
just different just a broad spectrum of
different types of people i get it yeah
well this like i say
so she's on here and one i don't think
she respects the process
which is so astounding to me because
ridiculous to me because
she's been on the show before so you
know how it is so she comes on the show
this one guy gets out of the car dale
and she's already like i think i've met
my husband
well he's like the type a man he
stepped up right away out of this whole
group of
how many 31 guys i don't even know how
many guys too many guys
um and he's the manly man he's the one
taking charge he's the one
and that other guy a lot of women
respect and the fact of he like sh she
was crying
he came over to hold on hold on hold on
hold on
that was way after i'm talking about he
got out of the car and she was like i
think i met my husband
okay that was a little extremely weird
that's what i'm saying she don't respect
the whole process like okay i understand
if you have a connection with this guy
you feel like
but she's not even allowing herself to
have a connection with anyone else
she's actually to me being rude and
disrespectful to these other guys
yeah i totally agree but there's also
that aspect of like
love at first sight um which i reject
when you know you know like that feeling
in your stomach when you should be
excited when you
i'm just saying i'm just also saying
that
you know like they're you have to listen
to your body as well and
like okay sometimes you're sexually
attracted to someone but you shouldn't
be with them
and maybe that's this guy dale you know
okay
listen i totally understand that all i'm
saying is you're on a show
like you're on a show that needs to go
you know 20 weeks
like you're on a show that you have to
like go through this process with the
roses and meet people
and she from like episode two she's
already like
on camera saying oh i wish this guy was
dale i wish i was with dale not this guy
you know what i mean it's like what are
you doing i think they're replacing her
i think they kind of teased that that
they were gonna like okay she's out and
they're gonna replace her
because these other guys are picking up
on it they're like what am i doing here
i'm leaving my family
okay so then okay well then you know
there's also the
the part where she's she came here for
love
she found love so of so if that's what
it is
congratulations she she did what she
came to do
and great so now there's all these other
guys though
and yeah they should have a replacement
okay here's the thing though she didn't
find love
she just found an infatuation for now
she just found an infatuation
you can't judge someone's love i'm
judging a woman i'm judging it because
she didn't even really know him
he don't know her she don't know him
then for her for for her just to be like
oh this is the one
like that just negates the whole process
of actually falling in love
of actually getting to know someone and
realizing that
your strengths and weaknesses their
likes and dislikes you can't just
meet somebody that walks out of a car
and be like this is the one you have to
prove it
i think that's i mean not that i watch a
lot of the show
obviously but i think within the series
they like bring them home to their
family and then
they go to her family and then i don't
know they kind of meet their friends and
stuff yeah but she's not even
but this is we haven't gone to that
they're not even going to get to that
they're replacing her because
she's already she's already ruining the
whole process
these guys all these guys are like why
am i here so then they had that one guy
who was completely out of line he was
actually out of line
and right at the same time yeah isn't
that weird you know
so like so then she did i talked about
this we could talk about it too like she
did this like
strip dodge ball okay i hated that so
she's having the guys play dodge ball
then they had to take their clothes off
and you're the one that brought it up to
me rachel says to me like can you
imagine if like the guy
bachelor made all the bachelorettes
take their clothes off like it was just
never literally
played strip dodge it was ridiculous
they had to blur everybody's junk
you know i was like so anyway one of the
guys i forgot his name
really first of all he was starting
smack he was starting trash
from the beginning because remember
episode one he was like
telling this other guy hey i know you
were dating one of my friends
and i think you should say something to
and so he brought it up to the girl
to the main he brought it up to the
bachelorette like hey this guy
it's like what are you doing why are you
starting stuff so then he sees this and
he says
well this is crass i would never play
that i think it's low class
my daughter is watching okay all right
dude i get it
i agree with him all right but then he
goes to her
and he like tells her off you know i
expect more from the
oldest bachelorette ever he's saying
that kind of stuff and i was like okay
you could say your piece
respectfully you know what i mean but i
just thought he was out of line
yeah don't you think yeah that's all
yeah yeah i guess i saw that way i guess
i said it all yeah
the guy was just out of line and he had
to go home then she's crying and
that's when your boy dale stepped in
like i got you girl
like i wonder if like he like it kind of
looked like
it looked and sounded like he was
already on his way to see her before he
knew
she was crying no i think they know they
heard everything it was like a big
commotion
but i don't know i feel like they're
gonna replace because like because they
showed some girl getting out of the pool
in the last episode
that was awkward yeah it was awkward
like are they replacing her with like
you know i found was funny was like okay
so she's white not that it matters but
she's white and like half the guys are
black
yeah one asian guy and now it looks like
they're gonna replace her
with a black girl you know and it's like
i wonder how that's going to play
even though it shouldn't matter but
that's kind of things do matter like you
know you wonder if these like you know
well there was actually this one time
that i applied
to a matchmaker show
and the truth comes out all the stuff
that we do
i never all the stories are all the real
stuff years before i ever met you it was
probably when i was 21
and um and i just
i did this audition i didn't like
go further than this little meeting that
i did
and she asked me she's like would you
want to date
black guys or or white guys does it
matter and i was like well it doesn't
matter and she's like
okay well the next person
for the show is a black guy do you want
to be on it or do you want to just
pass and so i was like you know what
i'm going to pass but
so like that so your racism came out
finally
i mean obviously i'm dating you and
you're black but
um i'm just saying like
that's how they at the time they were
like hey
but you know what though everybody's got
a preference and just because you have a
preference it doesn't mean you're wrong
for having your preference i mean
sometimes people are attracted to the
things that are around them like if
you're mother and father it's like
you're jewish
you know i'm sure your parents were like
i'm sure your mom would have wanted you
to be with some nice jewish boy you know
what i mean
but like it sometimes it doesn't work
like that but also sometimes that's
what's around you so that's what you go
for you know you go for people that look
like your dad you go for people to look
like your mom you go for these different
things and that
and that comes to like what they
actually look like you know i guess we
should take more time to actually get to
know people but sometimes people don't
do that
i mean yeah now that i think about it
and say that out loud like
no one should ever like say that do you
want someone exactly
like what color skin do you want them
even presenting it to you was actually
wrong because then it
just puts you in the stuff it puts you
in the frame of being like
well what do i want yeah is that
important
yeah obviously what i chose wasn't even
what i
like yeah yeah so that was weird
so anyway i don't know what but anyways
yeah anyways
anyways i don't know what's going on
with the bachelor at uh you know so
we'll keep watching
to see but i just it's just so and i i
say this to you all the time when we're
watching
i'm like it makes me so uncomfortable
yeah
it is uncomfortable watching her she's
watching her
it makes me uncomfortable yeah there's
like she gets annoyed and gets upset
every time like they don't all jump out
the chance to like
be with her but in that scenario it's
really hard to like
be that person to be like oh she's ready
okay
now's my chance to go whereas like just
the things you're just going with the
flow kinda
but even some of the things that she
says and how she says it and how she
like operates it's just it just
i don't know i think she's like i don't
sometimes i feel like
she's not there to actually find love
but she's there to finally
feel like a princess like finally
everybody's looking for me
and that's not to me that's not good
energy yeah right
in that case she should have just been
on a dating app
yeah just tinder just swiped yeah cause
that's what she basically
did she was swiping when the guys got
out of the car and she swiped right on
dale
well that's kind of also what they were
saying was like they've kind of been
talking on social media before the show
because they don't know for sure but
yeah
okay well you whatever
if you know that this person's gonna be
the bachelor bachelorette
would you have sent them a message
yeah yeah i didn't even think of that
possibly yeah just to kind of get a
heads up like what's up you know i'm
gonna be on the show girl yeah like some
pictures
exactly yo i'm about to see you on
wednesday boo
you know maybe he did do that who knows
yeah well my other show that i like to
watch and rachel
sometimes likes to watch is big bro
they got us every time the guy changed
it every single sometimes he's like
welcome to big brother then he would go
big brother
all stars so the the season's finally
over
the guy that won the first hoh
competition
cody he actually won cody was great and
he deserved to win right yeah
he was great he won numerous
competitions he maneuvered his way to
the end
and i'm glad that the jury wasn't bitter
and they respected the game and he won
9-0 which he should have
now the girl nicole or enzo like nicole
if she had won that last hoh
and she should she said she wouldn't
have done it but the only way to me
she would have won is she needed to kick
cody out
whoever kicked cody out was going to win
the uh window big brother
yeah i mean i like nicole she's very
likable
there's just something about her
attitude that she's like
she makes it a little fun yeah i i
wasn't a fan of hers the first time
around when she first won i didn't think
she deserved it
but now that i see her play how she
played the game this whole way
she played a good game she got all the
way to the end
but like okay so the origin i only
started watching big brother like maybe
five six years ago so
so the cody this guy that won he came in
second place on his original season
and he said that he lost because he was
loyal
to the the guy that won right and so
when the people were like well kind of
like the enzo
to him yes exactly exactly so he
he knew he was going to make the choice
i'm kicking out the person
that i'm not going to play loyalty game
i'm going to play
the best chance i have to win and enzo
was the best
he had enzo had no business being in the
final two
and that's right that could have been
anyone yeah it could have been anyone
you know what i mean
but he deserved to win i don't think he
deserved
but like enzo you know i'm talking about
cody
yeah because even though enzo gave a
good ending speech i thought maybe
are they gonna vote for it but no he
didn't even get one vote and they knew
like that consolation prize of him
getting fifty thousand dollars for
second place
i think the whole jury was like that
fifty thousand is enough for you because
you
just you know you you skated your way
all the way to the final so you're here
yeah so big brother was fun this year
but it was kind of anti-climactic and
boring because
nobody made any big moves the guy that
won he won the first competition he won
the last competition and he should have
won and he did
so hopefully next season it won't be an
all-star
excuse me we just had some dinner
hopefully um
the next season will be like exciting
people make some big moves and rachel
will watch with me from the beginning
you just get bored of it you were
started watching without me and i
just oh excuse me miss watches things
without me all the time okay what else
are we talking about
i think that's it for uh this time we
went through a lot i'm always glad when
you're on the podcast
my beautiful lady um there was a lot of
good comments last week after we had our
after we like talked to the people
wasn't on no no i mean the one that you
were on we had good comments on
could i don't look anymore yeah yeah
it's best not to look
she doesn't look at the comments anymore
but rachel will be on like you know
as much as she can be and i appreciate
you guys watching
riffing with griffin make sure you go to
the griffin with gryffin store
you know you can see that on my website
i see us all in the links and
everything's in the links down below if
you want to be on patreon
rachel and i are going to start doing
little other little mini episodes which
we'll put on which will be patreon only
um i'm doing my real world advice for a
grown-ass man i'm trying to make that
separate
too okay some i don't know i'm still
working it all out but
there'll be another episode of that on
wednesday so make sure if you guys have
one of those look out for my instagram
post that's at eric griffin that's gonna
be
tomorrow too i'm gonna do my instagram
post and then i'll be answering all
those questions on wednesday
but please continue to share subscribe
and follow watch
listen send comments i appreciate
you greatly anything from you rage
no
you have nothing no goodbyes to the fans
that you have like two or three
goodbye to you love you baby love you
alright guys thanks for watching